welcome back to YouTube space New York
I'm Jessica from compchomp and I'm here
on native laying about the amazing
intersection between language and code
you should be excited because we're
talking about passwords today and why
your password probably isn't as good as
you think it is I love cookies but while
they make the world's best dessert my
apps keep rejecting chocolate chip as my
password I will show you who's weak so I
have to capitalize a letter at a number
maybe throw in some geometric shapes and
secret Illuminati symbols finally an
acceptable password I am never going to
remember it
so why the Internet's gives me the
runaround how exactly did passwords stop
being well Birds welcome to compchomp
the only show on the internet where Shh
secrets in ye olden days the passwords
worked a little differently you would
walk up to that creepy islip thingy and
the people behind there would slide it
open and you had one shot to say the
magic word but now you can just sit
there spamming that paper with words you
can throw unpronounceable non words at
him and you can even knock on that door
from anywhere in the entire world
because that I slit is an innocent input
box and the peeper behind it is a
computer and to computers words are
nothing special they're just boring old
strings characters appearing one after
another after another after you get it
so this is a valid string but so is this
and even this which is an empty string
there are so many possibilities but you
know who doesn't actually see a string
full of possibilities here
the humans like you
maybe me we fall back on our intuitive
natural language to come up with strings
that mean something to us because we'd
like to remember our passwords and if
we're lucky we might get super clever
and like swap a letter for a number
behold my brilliance I took that three
and used it as an E but you know what
more often than not you are exactly as
clever as the next guy and you're busy
patting yourself on the back for that
don't believe me just look at this list
of most common passwords if you're one
of the wannabe spies who used trust no
one that's gotta hurt
kind of felt like you came up with that
one all on your own didn't it all is not
lost if your password is on that list
you can fix it it is time for you to do
what programmers call getting entropy no
get your mind out of the gutter that is
computer speak for being less
predictable and how do you become less
predictable by being random random you
know what maybe the next time you snooze
your alarm and you wake up late you
should just tell your boss you were
trying to get some entropy probably
won't work and you might get fired but
at least we'll all have a good laugh and
the reason that you needed that entropy
is because password hackers are getting
better and better at predicting even
things that seem totally unpredictable
you uh can't keep hiding behind those
little dots and asterisks I have so much
trouble saying the word asterisks trust
no one tried outwit them with a clever
spelling and a complex character but why
not just make your password longer in
password cracking tests done by one
senior security consultant an eight
character password took 8 days to crack
adding just one extra character bumped
that time up to 750 days and 11
characters that might take get this
17,000 years now that makes your bank
account a little safer it's a long time
for someone to try to get the dollar 50
that's left in my bank account the thing
is is that it might take 17,000 years
because predicting is actually about
probability look a hacker could randomly
decide to start by guessing trust Note 2
but they're gonna go with that list of
shame that includes trust no one and
they're gonna crack trust no one before
No - even if it's just like right before
because you know that the next sucker
whose password is getting hacked is
trust know - length and funny characters
they aren't the only things that make
something guessable take a look at this
it's a nice random hard to guess string
right ah totally totally not there is a
pattern here
can you guess it can you guess it stop
trying to guess with your eyes and guess
with the eyes of your fingers instead
tada this is not the entropy that you
were looking for so look I know how much
it hurts to have to change your password
every 90 days you can't reuse a previous
password you can't use real words bla
bla bla
I definitely feel it too but there is a
good reason why passwords aren't real
words anymore it's not because your
computer hates English or because the
programmer that made that program really
likes to give you the runaround and make
you play the password recovery game
every 90 days it's because words are
predictable subscribe to keep up with me
and see more of the code behind our
everyday lives
ciao